i literally can't stop thinking about
this goddamn game i want those better
power washers
i want to wash more things i just
i just want to wash things i just want
to wash them
is that so wrong that i just want to
wash i just want to wash things man
you know what i'm actually going to do
this power power nozzle style
what do i have nozzle super nozzle
oh see it's just the good stuff you know
what i mean it's just the good
stuff oh it's so good
i just i i can't i was literally
thinking about this game
like all day i was like oh man i
shouldn't i should do something else
but no i'm just i'm going to play it
because it's what i want to play i
go just look at it look at the power
look at the power
god i know i could do this soap and it'd
be done in a heartbeat but
honestly this is better this is where
the satisfaction
comes in oh yeah
what the hell what the hell sounds it
am i
what was that what kind of nightmare
hellscape did i just hear
did you guys hear that was that in my
world or was that in the game world
are they one in the same
[Music]
nice
why am i in a windy ass valley doesn't
make any sense also the power nozzle
seems to be missing spots which i think
is super weird
maybe i'm too far away
honestly it's not satisfying it's just
having this
oh yeah oh yeah more complete coverage
anyway
i really do need that wide beam i'll get
the power nozzle for like super detailed
interior things that are necessary but
as far as this goes why am i in the
valley of the wind
[Music]
there we go and really need to get in
there that's what we need that's what
this is for
are we looking up top not so great
that's okay
and almost done give this a once over
and then let's blast it with some soap
to finish it off give it a nice shine
there we go that's what i'm talking
about oh yeah
that is nice look at that thing go oh
god this is the greatest
[Music]
i can't even explain it clean is an egg
you're a legend nothing can stop me now
well until you get dirty again but then
come back to me and i'll do it i'll do
it upright
clean the bungalow or clean the
playground i'll clean the bungalow
because that looks devastating hey doc
you know i mentioned my folks
well i think it's time their bungalow
met your pressure washer it's so filthy
it's hard to tell where the ground ends
in the house begins
if you can give the place a good cleanup
i'm sure it'd give them both a lift
thanks again cal
well for that much money you got it you
got it but for
big jobs like this i am going to be
using the soap because my god
i'm not going to i'm not going to deal
with that oh the soap does run out after
a while all right cool well let's see
where should we begin well i guess on
the
i guess on the driveway ain't too bad
oh i can use my stone cleaner uh
don't have a stone yeah stone cleaner
here we go
there we go perfect
like a dream he's a volcanology he's a
volk
who's a volcanologist yeah not so much
pressure washing is just like
washing washing but man is that quicker
it is way faster just takes a couple
coats you know
oh i ran out of i ran out of stone
cleaner
really oh i
oh you really use it oh [ __ ]
oh you oh you really use it oh my god
okay well that's why i ran out okay
oh geez i didn't know it was that fast
whatever
if i'm gonna do the cleaner i should do
at least a spray down with the super
wide nozzle
just to get it prepped and that would
probably be faster i did see the option
to buy it
like straight up because otherwise like
this does this is like an hour-long job
and i do find this satisfying
but i would rather get my satisfac my
satisfaction
fix from quantity as opposed to or
qual qual quant quantity quantity
am i looking for quality or quantity
okay yeah so for example
super wide it just get it
hit with the super wide
just to drench it take care of some of
the easier stuff
then bust out my wood cleaner and let's
pop
the wood cleaner in there
clean his whistle
not clean as a whistle yee
[Music]
okay this is just this is just a
hellacious job
good god and i'm out but that's okay
because i'm going to refill there we go
easy see isn't that much better
if i was doing this house normally this
would take ages
but it is going to cost me a lot of
money that that is the thing it is oh
and it didn't even get everything
god damn it god damn you the crannies
and the nooks
how am i going to get up on the roof how
do you expect me to get up on the roof
i wonder if i could just do it because i
know
if i don't do anything it doesn't really
clean much at all actually
no it does nothing okay without a
cleaner in it it does
nothing
[Music]
okay so i'm getting progress i'm 20 of
this way through
um what i'm gonna have to do is even if
it costs more
money i just gotta go for it because
just the sheer speed at which it does it
like it's worth the money
maybe and maybe maybe not it's hard to
say
[Music]
i should have gotten the range extenders
that would have helped a lot on this
but i'm a fool and i didn't buy the
right things because i'm a fool
yeah see i ended up going through over
this wall again anyway just because
i miss the spots with the soap so if i
use the soap i really just got to use it
exactly where it needs to be used
there we go finally okay oh my god what
did a fire happen on the outside of this
house how did any of this get
uh anywhere you know i've never made so
many enemies
that the entire population of this town
decided to throw feces at my house
like this just like literally what else
could this be i'm not gonna assume
this is mud and if it is mud then
there's some explaining to do because
the grass here isn't muddy so clearly
this has been brought in
but i'm assuming this is feces now i
don't want to be judgmental maybe maybe
the sound sucks and everybody else no
everyone else's house is pristine and i
have not had that much business
why is your house terrible what is the
hoa said about you
you know honestly i think the straight
up blast works better than the turbo
nozzle
i was here just kind of salivating over
the turbo nozzle like
oh yeah it's gonna solve all my problems
honestly
not as good as just a pure blast i'm not
gonna lie
this in the yellow can almost solve all
of my problems okay
uh let me get the ladder oh yeah there
we go that'll be good
step ladder you're not my real ladder
guys i'm funny guys if you don't laugh
at me my channel will be deleted
instantaneously
you must laugh in the comments down
below if i don't get enough likes
mr youtube or mrs youtube is gonna come
down from youtube hq and delete my
channel
that's just a fact and if you guys don't
listen to distractible
i will personally show up in your closet
in the middle of the night and i will
emerge from it
and i will slam headphones on your head
and i will punch you until you listen to
it
it's up to you you have to press play i
can't make you do it it's your choice
after all
it's your choice anyway
[Music]
all right let's get the roof let's get
the roof i want to get the roof
i've got some other cleaning equipment
that i did buy and i want to make sure
that oh
window wait wow bungalow roof universal
because i mean i could use ah let's just
do it
and i'm out ma keeps messaging me they
get really excited with how it's looking
sounds like it's going great
are they in the house are they judging
me as i scream about how much poop is on
their windows
because that doesn't seem very good for
them i mean it's true they should be
concerned about this
they should be embarrassed about this
like they sh they should definitely be
embarrassed about this
i'm still doing this with a smile on my
face because this is still incredibly
satisfying
i don't know what it is what does it say
about me what does this say please tell
me i'm not alone in this like
i can't be the only one that is playing
this game with just glee
like full glee of cleaning like it's
so satisfying oh chimney clean
santa will be happy what if i like spot
clean the big stains
you know and then i go over everything
else
because it's generic is that a strategy
am i learning what happens if i fall and
die does that happen
can that happen is there fall damage in
this game it's a friendly fire could we
two-player this
if you could do a tube oh if you could
play this with a friend
i am dead now i'm going to sue you i'll
see you in court mister
mon paw if those are your real names
[Music]
god damn it did i see something down
there that wasn't clean
the wall where
where oh you're not clean either
mr frame oh what are you even doing
there you go oh okay there you go
oh you're not clean either god damn you
god damn you
[Music]
i think that was the least satisfying
way i've ever cleaned anything in this
game
that was not good i'd rather just be
meticulous about things i always come
back to that
i would rather just be meticulous isn't
this better oh isn't this
infinitely better oh it's so much better
i haven't written anything in it
nice pops is even out on his rocking
chair now having a look
is he it
pops don't lie to me man
[Music]
and clear why does it say poor truth is
like way
far from being done oh maybe the porch
roof on the underside is probably pretty
bad too
the bungalow roof however is very
demanding and says that there's a lot
more needed and i get it i get it i was
kind of a douche about it i didn't go
about it the right ways
probably the edges oh yeah you got a
major edge problem here
yeah your edges are all over the place
do you think there's real power washers
out there that take extra long to do
their job just because they want it to
last
like do you think they bring their power
washers home and use it for everything
how are you not done yet how are you not
done why have you not
opened your doors to the public
what have you done have i missed stuff i
mean uh clearly i have obviously
yeah i see i see little like micro specs
everywhere i really
i really couldn't have done this any
worse i i
get it i get it i i'm done with the soap
i'm done with the soap
it costs too much money uh it defeats
the whole
it defeats the whole purpose of power
washing in the first place
it's no bueno it's not satisfying
i'm not gonna do it anymore
oh you count as bungalow roof oh that's
why you're not getting anything
oh you're bungalow roof
oh
oh my god look at this post oh
i'm just trying to make this pillar
clean because just comparatively to
everything else
is so crazy
there we go it's clean good god
good good
this is better than that i hate to say
it
but the turbo nozzle kinda sucks
[Music]
this is one of those situations where
i'm gonna find out that these people
have been dead for like 27 years and
their ghosts were sitting on the porch
here looking at me
oh you have a pet a ghost pet unless
this is like a
freaking mountain lion those ate you
alive which would be more believable
look at that look at that god that's a
better strategy than anything i was
doing
one pass really is the way to do it i
guess
bam oh
yeah honestly uh i'm starting to realize
that kind of main
main nozzle just works because at the
end of the day it's about blasting it
with water like no matter what that's
that's the strategy you do that you
blast it with enough water and then
you're done
i guess it is just like right tool for
the job right
you just got to know what you're doing
how you're doing it i think i'm thinking
about this like a shower you know
like ah the ancillary splash will get
the rest of it
it's clean enough just standing in the
water is what will get you clean right
so i shower anyway oh my god get clean
already oh there
up there it was i missed it okay
all right what is the point of this
does nothing it does nothing
[Music]
i haven't talked in so long ah
he i have nothing to say
legitimately like i was in such a zone
there i was just enjoying myself
god i'm enjoying myself the god of power
wash has blessed me but also
robbed me of my soul i sold it for more
power
purely more washing power
[Music]
[Applause]
i did it again i went into a zone i went
into a zone
not that you guys need to see every
single bit of this but my god
i am really it's like hypnotizing you
know
like something about just being in the
work it's so meticulous but every single
second and everything a single speck of
dirt that you get off
is immensely satisfying like i was going
to try to make this like a quicker job
because i was like oh a whole house
that's going to take quite a while to do
and of course it was going to take a
while but i was like oh with the soap
and stuff it'll be fine
but honestly i don't wanna use the soap
number one it costs money but number two
it's not as satisfying
there we go finally that one done this
grime is thick
like i don't know why the grime at the
back of the porch the last stuff that i
was doing was the thickest but it is
thick back here like someone's come out
to smoke on this back porch for 30
000 years you know that coal fire in
pennsylvania that's been burning for
like 40 years
that's in this backyard almost done
getting excited
ah
that is nice
but apparently i'm missing eight percent
of something i not 100 sure where
there's eight percent left to
clean oh did i miss this sidewall i bet
i did oh i did i thought i had it all
i guess more for me to wash oh what a
shame
oh what a tragedy oh
so sad man that what is with these
stains
these stains are stubborn
[Music]
god these ones up top just won't go
okay either these stains are sun baked
in or like
my water pressure is dropped because
this is this is uh this is asinine
okay like i see some of you but it's
just like pure
sh ah what oh am i not done
oh oh am i not done posts
post post post post
post like a like a social media
post like a what kind of post are we
talking about here what
wait wall wall wall wall bungalow roof
what's happening post
these posts okay
oh i see sounds like a job for the turbo
nozzle
uh okay what do we got
post five of six what post is not
done i got all the posts i thought
didn't i get all the posts
am i dumb how dumb am i
trick question very
huh
that is a post
[Music]
and what else bricks bricks
bricks
oh oh
there we go look at that beauty
look at the beauty look at the that's a
volcano
ah volcanologist that makes sense to me
now oh now the playground with this
playground
i might be able to afford the other
power washer
oh this playground is going to give me
the other power washer oh
all right let's get this playground
those kids are [ __ ] disgusting
all those kids are so terrible literal
horrifying humans miniature humans
what's wrong with all of them we're
wrong literally any of them oh
i should have bought the extendos can i
go back and uh can i buy the extendos
i need the extendos can i get the
extenders thank you
give me the extension yeah give me that
like i'm trying to imagine a
neighborhood where every single
kid in this playground is pig pen
from peanuts like just with stink lines
dirt everywhere like a cloud of dust
following them
and just like just a general odor
because i imagine i'm glad i can't smell
this right now because if i could i
imagine it would be horrendous because
what are those stains
what are those can i just have this
thing spin like is there a way to get
this thing going because they would make
it a lot easier
to wash who calls it a roundabout it's a
merry-go-round
roundabout's the thing you drive on and
the thing that i build in city skylines
but don't fully understand but they say
that it all helps traffic flow
i don't know how to do it properly so
everyone just gets in a big old car
jam not an accident i don't think they
have accidents in that game
but they should i'm gonna just i know
that i said i wouldn't but
i feel like i have the metal cleaner so
i might as well right
how did i grab that how how did i grab
that i get the details are important but
i feel like i've really cleaned this
thing pretty good
okay there we go oh that took
a lot this is wood wood wood wood
oh yeah wood
oh it tells me what type of dirt grime
and dirt streaks
oh that's handy nice
what is this plastic plastic you say
i've got a plastic cleaner
my god
i just don't understand how kids can
just literally walk upstairs and not
poop themselves how does this happen who
let this happen what kind of city
ordinance only allowed me to come when
after it gotten this bad
is this after one day of use mud splats
yeah
mud splats yeah keep telling yourself
that mud splats
[Music]
hey you have an eyeball i didn't know
that oh you look cute
hopefully this is satisfying and i'm
hoping that when i get done
watching you you don't come to life that
is very nice
i am not going to lie it's very nice i
know it costs money but
god damn time efficiency you know let's
go back to
wood because i know i got more wood here
oh no that's plastic but this wood
oh my god yeah i'm only 18 of the way
through this this is a big
playground lots of things have happened
here
and there's just so much grime did you
hear about the mayor's cat ulysses
missing the whole town's on the lookout
for him in the past festival
we won't have till spring he's put that
hat on
oh i know where he is he's on that shed
well you guys didn't know about that
yeah he's on a shed i saw him to be
honest if i had to wear the head i'd go
to
yeah i tried to literally um power
washes anus
so i don't know if he's alive
i'm just hoping that this pays off after
all because this is just so
much to wash that like if i was to do
this all
by hand it would take forever
look i may not get that better upgraded
uh sprayer after this one but
honestly i'll get another job and i'll
make some more money
and i'll get it done and it'll all be
good
[Music]
good god
more more
this would have taken like two hours
i'm not gonna do this for two hours
there's so many nooks and crannies and
like yes it's satisfying that the colors
come out but my god
i gave you details to a colleague who
needs a hand with a new place in the
suburbs it's
the old diath place hopefully i hope you
don't get spooked easily
oh my god do you actually have a
freaking uh how did you refiner put
everything on hold my golf bug is soiled
like you wouldn't believe oh please give
me something like that
you know honestly the outdoor stuff i
can't do but if there's a haunted house
like i'm down for that uh and if there's
a vehicle i'm down for that
also i know i haven't gotten any money
because i haven't completed anything
with this stuff but
i'm gonna do finishing touches grab the
money and then as much money as i can
i'm not gonna worry about finishing this
one
because honestly these kids they're just
gonna dirty it up again so i'm not i'll
be back i'll have more business soon
they should be happy with what they have
this is impossible
this is absurd this is absurd this is
absurd i've spent
so much money on cleaner oh this is
where my career falls apart
god it's like thanos snapped but instead
of people turning into dust
they exploded in mud god they just
turned into mud and just got poof
everywhere how do you explain this and
now you know i know that i've screwed
myself because i spent too much money on
the the cleaning supply and now i'll
never get it back unless i
stick here and i just meticulously clean
everything
which is fine i'm willing to do that but
it's a hell of my own making
and i'd never like hells of my own
making i always need to blame
someone so i'm going to and that someone
is
you how did you enable me to do this
how is this your fault literally how
how have you done this to me how are
these monkey bars not done
give me the goddamn money it's
clean it's so clean it's shining
what about all the cleaners that i'm
using are these toxic to kids
it's gonna cause some horrible damage
probably oh there i see it
okay well i'm an idiot
ten dollars go i need so much more money
than that i'm gonna extort people for
money
god i've made 32 bucks from all this
because i've only partially cleaned
everything
it was 50 done oh playground floor okay
i can do that
[Music]
so not worth it i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go and i'm gonna golf cart
hundred bucks
you got it i'm in it to win it oh boy
okay perfect i love it
i love it i don't even care if i have to
do it all manually i
love it now this is what i am talking
about this is what i've always been
talking about
there we go that's the good stuff man
that is just
crusted on there that is some
crust
now this is satisfying this is where the
satisfaction really kicks in you just
look at it from different angles
you give it the business you do it right
and hey job well done at the end of the
day how did you get it on the inside of
the roof
god was this lost in a bog
i'd like to think i'm just doing
people's work when they recover these
things from deep underground
after the mole people has pulled them
down to the depths of hell
surprised there isn't more blood i'm
always surprised there isn't more blood
maybe that's weird that i keep asking my
clients where all the blood is
i'm just assuming the worst what else is
there
the seat cushion ah
all right there we go thank you so much
for that
really appreciate it oh there we go see
now i actually get to see the work in
progress
oh that's good that's really good that's
good
that's nice that's almost like the whole
thing never happened wait what happened
what did happen who did you kill who did
you kill
no i gotta go back to the playground i'm
resuming
oh god oh god just give me something
manageable
one at a time one at a time that's all i
got to do i got i got to take this one
at a time
this is my main problem with things as i
and this is actually a life lesson that
i need to learn i i try to do look at
jobs as one
big thing instead of a lot of little
things and it's much easier to tackle
life
and projects that you want to get done
if you look at it like a lot of little
things
like it's just this bench and it's so
much more satisfying because you get
that bite-sized piece of like
hell yeah i did that piece of it i
didn't need to do
all of it at once even though i'm going
to do all of this like
at once and i've been recording for an
hour and a half i just looked at that
but
it's fine i'm enjoying myself you guys
have not seen the labors of an hour and
a half but i just did that
i'm just gonna take a moment and i'm
gonna zen out like i'm just gonna get
into this because i do enjoy this
oh i do enjoy it and it is nice
and so i'm not going to worry about
trying to talk about anything i'm just
going to finish this playground
that's what i want to do because it is
real nice
[Music]
i still wonder why they use this fancy
pants shock absorbing rubber compound
not good old-fashioned creosote i don't
know
creosote sounds like one of those things
that boomers put into things
that causes cancer is this the
extraordinary dr power wash
got your details from cal we got a dirty
old house in need of some clc
yeah i'm kind of busy trying to make a
living here
i'll be with you in a bit look at that
oh this playground ain't too bad under
all the grime it's actually pretty
vibrant colors
[Music]
oh 40 bucks oh
god i really didn't do myself a service
by using up all the soap
god i just left so much little stuff
that's hard to find
oh i'm a fool
[Music]
oh
oh god it's such a it's such a
such a satisfying feeling when you
finally get it because i don't know
and it's just like dang i know that's
like all that hard work oh
boy it worked oh man i'm i'm in a hole i
am in a hole
and i don't want to climb out of it but
man i'm starting to want to but
god damn
[Music]
[Laughter]
god i'm doing it i can't believe it i'm
doing it oh my god i'm doing it
holy crap i'm doing it what the hell is
wrong with me
creosote is fungicidal cheap and
absolutely joy to poor
sure profoundly toxic to humans when
ingested aha
uh-huh uh
[Music]
ah oh my god oh everything except the
climbing pole
i gotta get that i gotta get that i
think everything except the climbing
pole and the playground is
done but i can get that i know it's the
tippy top
[Music]
oh i know the stegosaurus technically
not
fully done maybe i could finish it off
real quick i mean
the stego slide my apologies
[Music]
oh my god
my god oh the only thing i haven't done
is the floor and honestly screw the
floor
because wow i don't want to clean the
huh girl
but i can get 200 worth i know i've been
recording for like two hours
and i'm kind of greasy already from just
the amount of recording but i'm betting
that if i just go for some cheapy stuff
and and what what is that
what what is that i don't have time to
deal with whatever that is i'm just
gonna
oh let me get my extendu
oh isn't this a hot this is the haunted
house right you might notice the odd
super weird creepy sign on the outside
of the house it's nothing to worry about
oh yeah okay according to jenny's
research they're written in enochian the
ancient language of the angels
okay that's a little weird not 100 sure
what that's about
god if i hadn't gone on that soap spree
like i knew i shouldn't have i would
have so much more money right now
that's how i was flipping disgusting i'm
not even one percent of the way done
god damn this house is dirty god
damn
[Music]
is this the enochian that i'm rubbing
off is this gonna summon an angel to
come
kill me is that what we're dealing with
right now
oh my god the mold
the mold okay that is some caked on [ __ ]
that is rough i don't know how i'm gonna
get that i'm gonna need soap for that i
guess
or i'm gonna need a more powerful
pressure washer
okay 127.
bruh i just want this new
hose oh i know i want a new washer so
badly can i sell oh why did i buy so
much crap
can i sell my stuff oh the chimney's
bigger than i thought it would be
oh god oh my god
oh my god what are the details
i'm losing it i'm losing it i'm
fine i'm fine
i'm starting to lose it though why am i
starting to lose it why am i starting to
lose it
wait three hundred there's 200 bucks on
the ground here
i thought
but said this how did
[Music]
i don't know why but like in the back of
my mind like i i'm kind of
over it but at the same time back in my
mind i'm just like come on
just push just finish this playground
because this playground is like such a
tough
it was such a big job like there's so
much i've been doing it for hours but at
the same time like i'm like
i gotta finish it i have to finish it i
don't know what that
is it's just like i have to right
that's weird this is weird this is weird
it's just a game about cleaning what is
going on
[Music]
oh my god i'm almost done oh my god
i'm almost done oh my god
oh my god oh my god i'm actually stunned
i uh i really didn't think that i was
gonna finish this
like i super doubt it i've been
recording for almost two and a half
hours now of
just this of just washing of
and if if i've lost footage i'm going to
lose
my goddamn mind but i can't believe it
i'm actually gonna finish it
that's nuts that's nuts
oh my god
oh my god holy
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] oh
oh look how much look how much better it
is oh
look how much better it is oh look at my
battery oh
look how much better it is oh my god i
don't have any equipment for it but i
don't need it because i have all the
equipment that i need whoa
hey oh i don't have a soap nozzle but
that's a trap you don't even need that
oh my god nah nah yeah this one oh
[Music]
that feels good
oh look at her go well the real test is
going to be on the mold eh real test is
gonna be on the mold
like it ain't nothing like it ain't
nothing the mold just goes
oh oh look at the mold
go i wonder if even this oh even this
could probably do something
good oh my god it does oh
oh i am
so happy oh
i'm so happy i'm gonna be able to clean
so much better now
this is a dream come true this is
everything i've ever wanted i literally
wanted nothing else
oh as i sat on the sofa just now i heard
a strange psy-like sound yeah sure
whatever it was me
moaning and screaming outside oh i'm
gonna have so much fun with this
okay but that is all i'm i've got to get
out of here because if i don't i'm gonna
lose
every of my minds let me just compare it
to this i know i've already done this
but just like no no no not that
let's go back to the specials oh i don't
even know if i did
i don't even know where the hatch is
what is the hatch is the hatch like
is there like a mars base hatch
somewhere around here that i was
supposed to be
cleaning either way uh oh it only gives
me the stubby gun okay well
screw you anyway is there some kind of
hatch here
hatch hatch hatch
i knew it i knew there had to be
something hi how's it going
later nerd
job complete i can't believe you
remember
i can't believe you remember what i did
god it seemed so long ago that i did
that it really does
holy [ __ ] okay i'm done i'm out of here
thank you everybody so much for watching
i don't know how long this video is when
you watch about two and a half hours of
power washing
my hand is cramped up i'm feeling good
though thank you everybody so much for
watching
let me know what you thought down the
comments below
have you listened to distractible yet
it's very fun but that doesn't matter
now
link's in the description or just search
for destructible thank you and as always
i will see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
bye